et à farah d'heure avec dominique baudis
après bologne
l'enquêté piétine les avocats du suspect
arrêté hier déclare que le jeune italien
n'aurait pas quitté nice le jour de
l'attentât iran enfin un premier
ministre après quinze jours d'attentes
monsieur rajaï membres du parti de la
république islamique devraient être
investis ce soit deux voitures
économiques au prochain salon de l'auto
elle ne consommeront que 6 litres aux
100 en moyenne mais coûteront 25 % de
plus à l'achat
querelle autour des plages de la côte
d'azur
les écologistes contestent la sûreté des
prélèvements et l'efficacité de la lutte
contre la pollution
bonsoir marco à faty gâteau ce jeune
activiste italien soupçonné d'avoir
participé à l'attentât de bologne a été
placé sous écrou extraditionnel c'est
une expression un peu complexe mais en
clair cela signifie que la procédure
d'extradition a été engagée et la
chambre de mise en accusation devra se
prononcer pourtant à faty gâteau semble
parfaitement confiant je pense rester en
france
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré ce matin en
arrivant au palais de justice de nice le
jeune italien étaient revenus
vous voyez sur ces images d'un jean et
d'un tee shirt il est arrivé en fourgon
cellulaire
les menottes aux poings et il portait
une très épaisse barbe noire c'est un
détail qui a son importance en effet le
portrait robot établi par les policiers
italiens d'après les témoignages des
survivants de la gare de bologne se
portait robot c'était le visage d'un
homme sans barbe
il est évident que l'avocat de fatigue à
tous ne manquera pas de souligner cette
contradiction d'ailleurs ses défenseurs
parmi lesquels un ancien avocat de
spaggiari dans la sphère des hold up de
nice
ses défenseurs affirment que leur client
dispose d'un très solide alibi
plusieurs personnes auraient vu à nice
samedi dernier le jour même du carnage
de bologne
parmi ces témoins des proches et des
amis mais aussi des commerçants du
quartier où vivait le jeune activiste un
garçon apparemment sans histoire mais ce
jeune homme tranquille était en fait
l'un des cerveaux du terrorisme néo
fasciste en italie il lui est en france
depuis un an
éric gilbert
les apparences en tout cas sont
rassurantes depuis le mois de mai à faty
gâteaux étaient employés dans cette
clinique comme plongeur pour un salaire
de 2400 francs par mois un ami l'avait
présenté comme un étudiant en droit
obligés de travailler pour payer ses
études sa carte de travail sont permis
de séjour était en règle et la direction
de la clinique du belvédère n'a pas eu à
se plaindre à faty gâteau était un
employé ponctuel et sérieux il ne s'est
apparemment pas santé durant cette
période le registre de l'établissement
où sont notés les prises de service du
personnel indique simplement que le
jeune italien était en congé durant le
week end dernier
mais d'après certaines déclarations à
faty gâteau aurait été vu à nice le
matin même de l'attentât de bologne
plus surprenant tout de même le fait
qu'à fatigue apte au travail et au smig
alors qu'il occupait puis sous louer
deux appartements dans le même immeuble
avenue de castellane mais les
perquisitions entreprises de ce côté là
n'ont apparemment rien donne étonnante
également pour un homme recherché cette
plaque car fatiga tôt avait fait apposer
à son dernier domicile près du port de
nice
c'est un garçon qui était assez
sympathique la première course comme ça
mais en plus on discute et les sang et
or qui la maintient en fermant les deux
bêtes et de combien sont ils à cap-chat
discret oui c'est vrai par une petite
fête qui avait donné là il ya quelques
temps on n'avait pas ce cadre de lui
aussi après avoir manifesté leur
satisfaction les policiers italiens se
montre-t-il maintenant très prudent tout
repose sur un seul témoignage faisant
état d'une ressemblance
admettons ce soir à bologne marco à faty
gâteau qui a été transféré du palais de
justice à la maison d'arrêt de nice
semble en tout cas très sûr de lui
en tout état de cause la chambre
d'accusation qui doit statuer sur la
demande d'extradition ne pourra donner
sa réponse avant plusieurs jours
l'actualité à l'étranger maintenant deux
éléments nouveaux en iran aujourd'hui le
premier ministre pourrait être
officiellement nommé d'une heure ou d'un
jour à l'autre il s'agirait de monsieur
mohamed ali rajaï c'est l'une des
personnalités du parti islamique
le parti des ayatollahs l'autre élément
nouveau c'est un discours de monsieur
gods ad devant les députés très
attaquées par les religieux qui lui
reprochent de manquer d'intransigeance
islamique sadek go daddy a contre
attaqué il affirme qu'il ne veut plus
participer au prochain gouvernement
et puis je le rappelle pendant huit mois
j'ai porté sur mes épaules le problème
des otages et à la tribune du parlement
il a eu cette phrase il existe des
conventions internationales que nous
n'avons malheureusement pas respecté
françois-xavier d'eau ali rajaï probable
premier ministre d'iran et député du
terrain il est âgé de 47 ans et fut
ministre de l'éducation nationale du
gouvernement bazarde comme on pouvait
s'y attendre il est membre du parti de
la république islamique
c'est à dire du parti ultra-religieux
majoritaire à l'assemblée
cette appartenance indique assez quelles
seront les limites du pouvoir de
monsieur rajaï et sans doute aussi celle
du pouvoir du président de la république
monsieur bani sadr le différend entre
l'assemblée ce dernier différend qui ont
empêché la nomination d'un premier
ministre a été réglé en faveur du
parlement c'est à dire du parti
république islamique par l'ayatollah
khomeiny
c'est un signe de plus pour l'avenir
tout comme monsieur ben saad
monsieur rajaï ne sera libre de faire
aucune autre politique que celle des
extrémistes religieux d'iran dans l'est
pas moins à l'heure de la zizanie
monsieur runs à des ministres des
affaires étrangères s'exprimant devant
le parlement a déclaré tout net qu'il en
avait assez
il accepterait aucun poste dans le
nouveau gouvernement qu'il fallait dire
clairement une fois pour toutes si
l'iran respecte et ou non les
conventions internationales et accepter
les conséquences de la décision prise il
est peu probable que ces considérations
influeront sur la politique de
l'ayatollah khomeini
dans le dernier slogan reste mort aux
états unis mort à israël mort à l'urss
place de programmes comme on le voit
elles sont françaises elles sont deux
elles sont jolies
elle s'appelle eve et verra les ailes
ont paraît-il pour principale qualité le
sens de l'économie et elles seront
offertes au public en 1985 pourtant dès
ce soir en avant première
michel chevalet va lever le voile et
vous faire découvrir eve et vera qui ont
vu le jour
l'une dans les bureaux d'étude de la
régie renault 7e et l'autre verra chez
peugeot citroën ce sont des voitures
économiques de l'avenir on peut dire que
ce sont les voitures de la crise de
l'énergie elle consomme d'en moyenne 30
% de moins que les modèles actuels la
consommation actuelle moyenne et de vie
litres au cent et bien avec ses deux
voitures on parvient à 6 litres aux cent
eh bien à 4 litres et demi à 90 km/heure
on les verra bien sûr au salon de l'auto
mais michel chevalet nous les fait
découvrir dès ce soir
le premier a été développé il s'agit je
précise bien d'un brouillon par le
groupe peugeot citroën talbot regardez
elle s'appelle verra on a d'abord
travaillé
l'aérodynamisme du véhicule toujours en
partant d'une base de 305 et vous voyez
que par exemple on à retravailler
l'avant on a digne mais l'entraîneur du
radiateur
le pare chocs se transforme en boucliers
en spoilers les enjoliveurs de roues
sont très lisse les passages de roues
vous voyez on cette forme insolite de
façon à éviter les turbulences le pare
brise est un pare-brise coller de façon
à éviter le bourrelet de caoutchouc qui
provoque toujours les turbulences ici ça
vous y êtes habitués maintenant c'est le
déflecteur des vitres les parois sont
très lisse les poignées de portes ne
dépasse pas à l'arrière ici vous voyez
ce galbe devant la roue arrière toujours
pour éviter les turbulences et sur le
coffre pour réduire ce qu'on appelle le
culot de traîner car l'effet de succion
il y avait 12 y est habitué maintenant
cet aileron gain est bien près d'un
quart sur le coefficient de forme c'est
à dire sur la pénétration dans l'air de
l'autre côté vous avez le deuxième
prototype développé cette fois ci par la
régie renault
il s'agit dave est également mais là
cette fois ci on a travaillé
l'aérodynamisme à partir d'une forme
entièrement nouvelle et vous voyez le
résultat
on allie j'allais dire l'élégance à la
qualité des formes avec des formes très
molle très arrondi très lisse à pare
brise très incliné pour éviter le
décollement des filets d'air mais le
deuxième pari a été gagné non plus aux
organismes et sur l'allègement des
véhicules
prenons un exemple verra au départ c'est
une structure de 305 900 kg on arrive à
gagner 160 kg comment est bien par
exemple en étudiant des parois des ailes
et des portes que je tiens à la main
vous voyez en polyester armé de fibre de
verre
on a également pensé à utiliser
l'aluminium je vous donne un autre
exemple vous voyez ça c'est le réservoir
à essence 2 verra bien 52% sur le pwa
simplement en utilisant l'aluminium est
est ce que ce seront nos véhicules
ouvert dans la rue alors là par contre
il ya encore un point à franchir c'est
que le modèle 85 sont en cours
définition pour les constructeurs et les
voitures que vous construit conduirait
dans quatre ou cinq heures ne sont pas
assez mauvaise
les enfants simplement inspiré et les
constructeurs décident actuellement de
la nature exacte des voitures qui vont
construire et les distances de ses
modèles probatoire est pour eux est
extrêmement précieuse parce que c'est à
partir de ces éléments là qui conçoivent
les véhicules de 1985 donc économies
d'énergie d'accord mais qui va payer la
note car il faut bien les payer
il y aura effectivement un coût
supplémentaire sont des voitures plus
perfectionnés qui économise du carburant
mais qui coûte plus cher on ne connaît
pas encore le surcoût une hypothèse de
l'ordre de 15 à 20 % de plus mais en
contrepartie vous avez les économies de
carburant qui fait qu'au total les
automobilistes d'après nos enquêtes sont
prêts à payer ce léger surcoût par suite
des réductions des frais de
fonctionnement annuels
quand vous conduisez cette voiture
l'eau de mer de la côte d'azur est elle
dangereuse pour les baigneurs c'est ce
qu'affirment plusieurs mouvements
écologistes de la région selon
lesquelles l'eau de la côte d'azur
seraient malsaines et contaminer les
responsables de la lutte anti pollution
ne sont évidemment pas d'accord il
précise que des analyses sont effectuées
très régulièrement
quoi qu'il en soit il est vrai que cette
côte et notamment le département des
alpes-maritimes manque cruellement de
station d'épuration les pouvoirs publics
ont d'ailleurs lancé un vaste programme
d'assainissement un programme coûteux
chiffré à un milliard et demi de francs
coûteux et long puisque sa réalisation
s'étalera sur les dix prochaines années
alors en attendant quelle est la
situation
une enquête de jean pierre hamon
tous les jours deux avions rallye du
centre d'intervention contre la
pollution surveille constamment les 120
km de plage des alpes-maritimes ils ont
pour mission de détecter les déchets qui
sont déversées en mer soit par les
égouts soit par les bateaux il faut dire
que dans les alpes-maritimes la
population qui est de 1 million l'hiver
prince à 2 millions l'été et il n'y a
que deux stations d'épuration à cannes
et à cagnes sur mer
la ville de nice 1 million d'habitants
l'été n'a pas encore de stations
d'épuration sept jours une centaine des
goûts des verse 300 millions de litres
d'eaux usées directement dans la mer dès
qu'une pollution est repéré cinq
embarcations poubelle baptisé pélican
interviennent pour inspirer mazoutés
ordures pour les responsables il n'y a à
l'heure actuelle aucun danger
nous avons raccorder la plupart des
petits émissaires dans des grands
émissaire long qui débouche par 100
mètres de profondeur à plus d'un
kilomètre de rivage et par conséquent
sur le plan sanitaire on peut considérer
car 1980 l'étal des zones de baignade
est particulièrement propre les
écologistes bien sûr ne sont pas
d'accord ils se sont réunis la semaine
dernière ici à saint laurent du var
à côté de cet égout qui se déversent
directement dans la mer pour eux la
propreté des eaux de baignade est
douteuse et provoque des maladies
personnellement j'ai eu à constater
quelques infections en particulier au
niveau de la peau cutanée qui montre que
la pollution est réel sur nos plages
les écologistes contestent les résultats
des analyses effectuées par le centre
d'intervention contre la pollution
il affirme que lorsque les analyses sont
mauvaises elles ne sont pas publiés et
qu'aucun beyern en est informé ils
prennent pour exemple certaines plages
de nice à côté du port et surtout celle
de saint laurent du var
ici on nous dit que c'est l'eau est de
bonne qualité
moi je dis qu'il ya ça l'a rendu varlot
n'est pas de bonne qualité lorsque voyez
le le fleuve le var qui rejette tous les
déchets ici moi j que la place n'est pas
de bonne qualité à ces attaques les
responsables répondent que leurs
analyses sont effectuées suivant des
normes internationales je dis pas
qu'elle est clair
elle est propre à la baignade nous avons
quelquefois quelques pollution que
j'appellerais visuel mais qui ne sont
pas du tout dangereux ses positions ces
pollutions visuelles sont constitués par
des corps flottants ou des plastiques à
demi immergé qui nous viennent soit
d'italie a mené par le courant ligure
évidemment c'est désagréable
nous luttons comme nous pouvons contre
ce phénomène mais il ya un 120 km de
côtes
on peut pas être partout à la fois les
baigneurs ne sont pas toujours convaincu
par ses arguments il continue à aller
sur la plage mais beaucoup d'entre eux
hésitent entrer dans l'eau naturellement
dollars l'état va consacrer un milliard
et demi à l'assainissement du littoral
les écologistes le savent mais ils sont
décidés à rester vigilants jusqu'à la
mise en service des stations d'épuration
de nice et de marseille hier et comme
chaque année depuis 35 ans hiroshima
célébrer l'anniversaire de son martyre
nucléaire une autre cérémonie du
souvenir se déroulera à nagasaki seconde
cible des deux bombes atomiques
américaines de 1945
il faut rappeler le bilan de ces deux
explosions cent quarante mille victimes
auxquelles sont venues s'ajouter
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de morts
qui ont succombé par la suite le maire
de la ville a lu devant les quarante
mille personnes que vous voyez rassemblé
une déclaration de paix invitant
l'humanité à s'écarter de
l'autodestruction
justement en 35 ans après hiroshima
les etats unis adoptent officiellement
une nouvelle stratégie nucléaire jimmy
carter a signé un document un document
intitulé directives présidentielles 59
c'est un texte qui formule une nouvelle
doctrine de l'emploi de l'arme atomique
il confirme l'abandon progressif de la
stratégie qu'on appelle anti cité c'est
à dire leur stratégie dirigée contre les
villes au profit d'une autre stratégie
baptisée anti fort c'est-à-dire dirigées
contre des objectifs militaires c'est
donc l'abandon de la stratégie qui a été
appliquée à hiroshima francs soit en
quelque sorte oui et il est intéressant
de revoir comment a été décidé
justement ce raid sur hiroshima voir sur
une reconstitution cinématographique
il y avait une raison la bombe que vous
allez employés n'est pas une bombe de
500 kg ni une super donc dix mille kilos
et la halle puissance de 20 mille tonnes
de tnt envoyé quelques semaines plus tôt
à l'homo gordo les américains pour la
première fois expérimenté avec succès la
bombe atomique et où si tous les
physiciens les pères de la bombe
atomique ont écrit au gouvernement
américain en disant surtout il ne faut
pas employer cette seconde sur une cité
faut pas faire ce raid que voyait se
dérouler ce qu'il faut c'est faire une
démonstration monde entier pour qu'elle
ait un effet dissuasif seulement voilà
les états unis l'avaient d'abord que
deux bons ils se sont dit si nous en
utilisons une pour une démonstration il
n'en reste qu'une et si les services
japonais de renseignement le ca il ne
capitulerons pas et d'autre part faire
circuler l'information sur cette arme
nouvelle vis-à-vis d'un ennemi en pleine
guerre est bien évidemment ce n'était
pas facile et finalement voilà ce qui
fut fait et ceux qui étaient décidées
contre la volonté donc des pères de la
bombe atomique qui dès juillet 1945
souhaité qu'on applique la dissuasion
mais alors comment se fait-il que le
phénomène hiroshima ne soit pas
reproduit alors qu'il ya eu depuis
dissémination des armes nucléaires mais
c'est à dire que très rapidement les
grandes puissances ont eu un arsenal
nucléaire complet qu'elles ont en
quelque sorte montrer afficher une telle
information de la puissance de part et
d'autre et la dissuasion chéri la
dissuasion
seulement alors ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est que ça pourrait ne plus
jouer dans l'avenir pourquoi
eh bien réfléchissons en 1945 au fond
les etats unis se sont trouvés dans la
situation d'un pays qui a fait en ne
pourrait presque dire qui a pris coller
une force nucléaire très rudimentaire
dans la semi-clandestinité et au moment
de l'utiliser il ne peut pas écrire dans
sa dissuasion et donc vous avez vu ils
sont d'une employée
or aujourd'hui on voit beaucoup de pays
dans le monde qui de façon plus ou moins
clandestine essaye de se doter d'armes
nucléaires très rudimentaire et bien si
un jour il nous avait ses armes il se
trouvait dans un conflit
il serait dans la situation finalement
des états unis de 1945
c'est à dire qu'au moment de prendre
leur menace personne ne saurait
exactement quelles sont les armes qu'ils
ont quelle crédibilité et
on doit leur accorder la dissuasion ne
jouerai pas et alors on reviendrait dans
le quatrième film à à l'emploi voilà
pourquoi la dissuasion de l'armé
nucléaire
est ce que l'on devine comme processus
de fabrication d'armes clandestine ici
ou là est tellement dangereux pour
l'humanité
ce serait nous ramener dans le cas de
figure d'hiroshi journée une immense
foule s'est réunie aujourd'hui dans la
cathédrale de clermont ferrand autour du
cercueil de patrick de paille et sa
famille ses amis mais aussi bien sûr
tous ses camarades du sport automobile
patrick de payet je vous le rappelle
était âgé de 36 ans il était père d'un
petit garçon
on ne connaît toujours pas les causes
précises de l'accident qui lui a coûté
la vie le 1er août dernier
on sait seulement qu'il s'agit d'une
défaillance mécanique dont la nature
n'est toujours pas connue les images de
la cérémonie
et quand bien même nous connaîtrions les
causes de cet accident fatal que cela ne
changerait rien oui malheureusement rien
si ce n'est que pour la grande famille
du sport automobile patrick de paille et
restera présent immortalisé dans les
mémoires les livres et les palmarès car
il était un héros et les héros ne
meurent jamais 15 cents personnes
étaient réunies dans la cathédrale de
clermont ferrand pour rondes un dernier
hommage au pilote disparu les un anonyme
les autres amis proches membres de la
famille ou ville encore ses compagnons
d'aventuré
une aventure qui parfois se paie par des
larmes de la tristesse de l'émotion mais
aussi par du respect pour l'homme que
chacun côtoyaient et apprécié alan jones
jody scheckter et les pilotes français
et cette fois réunis sur la même ligne
en pensant certainement que cela
n'arrive qu'aux autres
l'inhumation a eu lieu en fin de matinée
à gré dans la benne un petit village du
puy de dôme
pas de vacances pour le parti communiste
au cours d'une conférence de presse cet
après midi charles fiterman a formulé un
certain nombre de propositions
propositions pour une relance immédiate
de l'activité que de mic pour ce faire
le parti communiste propose l'injection
de 20 milliards de francs destiné à
sauvegarder les secteurs en difficulté
20 milliards pouvant être dégagé grâce à
un prélèvement exceptionnel sur les
profits et les fortunes une sorte
d'impôt emploi le pc en cette période de
creux de l'été tient à être actif pas de
mois d'août pour le parti communiste il
sera présent partout dans les
entreprises dans les conflits sociaux
partout il occupera le terrain
écoutez à ce propos charles fiterman
il n'y a pas de vacances pour
l'austérité et pour la casse
il n'y en aura pas pour l'action des
communistes au service des travailleurs
et de leurs familles monsieur giscard
d'estaing et les forces qu'il représente
et qui le soutiennent ferait bien de
prendre garde
le mécontentement est très profond dans
le pays
plus il y a dans un secteur de la colère
les travailleurs n'accepte pas les
mauvais coups nous sommes décidés à tout
faire pour les aider à développer leur
lutte
nous sommes décidés à mener la vie dure
à ce pouvoir
impitoyable et à ce patronat rapaces
face à ces agressions nous sommes-nous
déterminé à rendre coup pour coup et
même deux coups pour un seul si c'est
nécessaire à boulogne-sur-mer le conflit
entre les marins pêcheurs et les
armateurs est toujours dans l'impasse la
situation reste tendue les quarante cinq
chalutiers sont toujours à quai et
depuis ce matin les marins occupe la
gare démarrer empêchant ainsi tout
commerce de poisson jusque là les
propositions patronales ont été rejetées
par les pêcheurs les syndicats doivent
formuler de nouvelles propositions aux
armateurs raymond barre a demandé au
ministre du travail jean matteoli de
recevoir une délégation de la cgt
raymond barre en avertit lui même
georges séguy en répondant la lettre que
le secrétaire général de la cgt lui
avait envoyé hier la cgt demandé à leur
gouvernement de prendre des mesures
urgentes afin d'aider les travailleurs
qui se trouve actuellement dans une
situation difficile
trois militants du front de libération
nationale de la corse ont été arrêtés
hier à tarascon à marseille on appris
aujourd'hui l'un des hommes a reconnu
avoir participé à l'attentât effectué le
14 mai dernier contre les gendarmes
mobiles en faction devant l'ambassade
d'iran à paris attentat qui avait fait
quatre blessés
incendies de forêt toujours dans le midi
notamment dans l'hérault et dans l'aude
incendie plus inquiétant aujourd'hui à
cause d'un vent très violent plusieurs
canadairs ont dû être appelés en renfort
80 hectares de forêt de garrigues ont
été détruits cet après midi dans le
massif de la crampe près d'eux
bonnes nouvelles explosions de voitures
piégées à beyrouth explosion qui a fait
un mort et trente blessés
c'est le deuxième attentat de ce jour en
moins d'une semaine dans le quartier
chrétien de la capitale libanaise en
afghanistan et aux rues de violents
combats dans la province du kandahar
selon les rebelles 150 soviétique et
afghans auraient été tuées en quatre
jours
les rebelles auraient même abattu deux
avions à réaction et attaqué le siège de
la gendarmerie ceci d'après l'alliance
islamique pour la libération de
l'afghanistan récolte record de céréales
cette année pour la communauté
économique européenne malgré le mauvais
temps du début d'été la récolte des neuf
est estimé à plus de 42 millions de
tonnes contre 40 millions en 1979 après
avoir ravagé la martinique haïti la
jamaïque est là j'aime qu'il y avait
huit morts et des centaines de sans abri
le cyclone allen menace maintenant cuba
on signale déjà quatre morts un maximum
de précautions étaient prises des vols
intérieurs ont été annulés et 110 mille
personnes ont été évacuées
allen a déjà fait plus de 70 morts c'est
le cyclone vous le savez le plus violent
depuis le début du siècle
l'ouverture de la pêche aura bien lieu
le 5 octobre pour la moitié nord de la
france
pas question d'avancer les dates
d'ouverture déclare-t-on au ministère de
l'environnement pour les 47 départements
du sud de la loire et de l'est de la
france
ouverture est prévue le 14 septembre le
21 septembre pour l'allier les charentes
et la haute vienne le 28 septembre en
saône et loire dans la meuse et en
meurthe-et-moselle
le capitaine y le premier pilote d'un
super pétrolier libérien viennent d'être
condamnés à quatre mois de prison ferme
par le tribunal de rotterdam leur
pétrolier s'était brisé en deux lors de
son chargement dans le port de rotterdam
le trafic alors bien évidemment été
considérablement perturbé on a redouté
aussi une explosion les officiers sont
responsables de cet incident responsable
de la mauvaise répartition de la
cargaison dans les soutes centrale
et puis vandalisme à tout âge trois
enfants le plus jeune n'avait que 5 ans
ont saccagé une école maternelle en
meurthe et moselle
une dizaine de milliers de francs de
dégâts en tout et quatre petits voyous
ne sont pas arrêtées là
ils se sont acharnés ensuite sur un
couple de tourterelles ils ont reconduit
les oiseaux de peinture et ils ont alors
consciencieusement arracher les ailes
puis une dernière information nous avons
appris tout à l'heure qu'il y avait eu
cette nuit une explosion au domicile
d'un libraire à saint germain en laye en
fait n'est pas deux libraires qui était
visé mais anonyme savant atomiste
français ce savant atomiste français et
un haut responsable travaillant sur le
projet de réacteur nucléaire de
recherche qui est destiné à l'irak est
la cible était le comité pour la
sauvegarde de la révolution islamique le
temps il a fait bien chaud aujourd'hui
sur l'ensemble de la france un
thermomètre dépasse et souvent 25 degrés
avec même des pointes de 31 à clermont
ferrand et 32 à toulouse en revanche
l'extrémité ouest de la bretagne et le
pays basque ont connu un ciel couvert
les températures un peu plus basse si
elle couvert également demain avec des
pluies sur les régions s'étendant de la
manche aux ardennes et au massif central
quelques orages éclateront sur le relief
et puis demain aussi un concert d'orgue
en l'église saint-germain-des-prés
pierre yves hasselin interprétera les
grandes toccata c'est un organiste âgé
de 30 ans il est né à montréal et depuis
1975 il est établi à paris où il
enseigne au conservatoire supérieur de
musique ses recherches portent
spécialement sur la conjugaison de
l'orgue et du calcin patrice de revel a
rencontré aujourd'hui alors qu'il
répétait aux claviers des grandes orgues
de saint germain des prés
voilà la première fois que j'ai joué de
l'orgue ça a été presque 25 ans
maintenant c'était à montréal
mon père est un maître de chapelle et il
m'avait amené à l'église jour des rois
et à la fin de l'année l'organisme avait
joué
pièce dans laquelle
fallait maintenir un son aigu sur
clavier qui devait symboliser les toiles
ils disaient les images alors c'est de
cette façon que j'ai l'impression que
j'ai dû
par un groupe plus ou moins alors ce qu
a entendu au début c'était un extrait de
la célèbre saga des faits dans les
mineures sébastien bach
il y avait presque tout toute la
puissance de l'or c'est dire si la tâche
que vous allez à l'exemple d'un sont
graves
parce que l'orgue comprend toute une
échelle de sonorités or je peux vous
donner l'exemple de son gras c'est le
plus grave devant
comme sont plus aiguës assez tôt à
l'extrémité complète supérieur demande
même trempé de l'entente soit raison
voilà vous pouvez me rejoint un petit
peu je peux toujours oui je peux
reprocher la même toccata de bach envoyé
que j'actionne tous les mécanismes pour
mettre les différents jeux
je vais poursuivre au point où j'en
étais
avant de vous quitter une petite
rectification tout à l'heure nous avons
parlé du 5 octobre en indiquant que ce
serait la date de l'ouverture de la
pêche c'était une erreur ce sera
l'ouverture de la chasse je pense que ne
passionné de chasse auront rectifié
d'eux-mêmes
c'est joseph poli qui vous présentera la
dernière édition de tf1 qualité bonne
soirée merci de votre attention